hello everyone today's matchup is an
all-time slugfest between two of the
cutest dolls to ever go on a murderous
rampage Chucky vs. Annabelle Geppetto's
fever dream who will be the top Titan of
toy terror who will be the most powerful
possessed puppet alliteration it's not
just for poets anymore here's how it
works
round one box office round two tomato
meter round three killed and then we'll
have a wild card round then you the
viewer will determine our winner
they got no strings to hold them down so
let's get it on ran one box office
chucky paved the way for Annabelle
there's no doubt about it the first
child's play was released way back in
1988 and that still holds the record for
highest grossing Chucky movie when
adjusted for inflation and a domestic
take of 73 million dollars Annabelle was
hot out of the gate with help from her
larger at the conjuring universe that
first conjuring movie where she did a
little more than make a cameo made a
hundred and fifty eight million dollars
domestically that franchise boost really
helps because Annabelle crushes Chucky
with both per movie averages 114 point 5
million for her fifty point four million
for him and in total box-office receipts
she's got four hundred and fifty eight
million dollars in the bank he only has
252 million dollars and Annabelle has
accomplished this feat in only four
movies it took Chucky five films the way
of box office numbers for and because we
have no idea how much money Chucky gets
from red box rentals I'm giving this
round one in a decisive win to Annabelle
round two tomato meter Chucky needs a
win and him defeating anyone and it's a
mate ohmmeter battle is far-fetched or
so it would appear that way you [ __ ]
with me
the little buddy has seven movies that
average are you ready for this fifty
three point one four percent that's not
bad and it gets even better when you
consider the recent uptick in approval
ratings so seed of Chucky was only
thirty three percent but since then his
two most recent efforts curse of chucky
and cult of have garnered fresh numbers
at seventy six percent and seventy seven
percent respectively
that's a cult I want to be a part of
should I not say that holy [ __ ] and they
call me sick meanwhile Annabelle has a
four movie average of 66 percent on the
tomato meter but and this is a sir
mix-a-lot level but that stat is padded
with help from the conjuring movies and
Abele's two solo efforts have combined
for a 49.5% average she started off
rocky with just 29% for the first
Annabelle and then rebounded nicely with
70% for the prequel Annabelle creation
but Chucky has been doing it better for
longer and he is gonna take a shocking
win in round number two round three
killed so being a murderer's doll is a
great life everyone fears you respects
you and you get a nice chunk of
merchandise sales amazing isn't it but
when it all comes down to it can you
kill the stats don't lie and Chucky has
built up a resume that would make Freddy
and Jason blush the little doll has
offed 44 people he's just a little toy
how are we all getting murdered
meanwhile Annabelle she takes her sweet
time with kills she only has three like
total kits 44 to 3 this is a blowout
victory for Chucky buddy I'm gonna give
Annabelle some credit here she has some
meticulous methods of murder I didn't
say I was done with alliteration in
Annabelle creation she messed up Anthony
LaPaglia is hand real good remember she
bent it like backwards when he had the
cross and she cut Miranda Otto in half
but Chucky has all sorts of creative
ways to end fictional lives head smash
wire decapitation TV into the bathtub
good old-fashioned knives and remember
when he traded Khalil Mac to the Bears
it's a Jon Gruden joke if you follow
sports it's really funny good luck in
Vegas Chucky
you win this round you know what they
say you just can't keep a good guy down
wild card round creation story both of
our cuddly antagonists have been on
quite a road to get here believe it or
not both did start out as just toys
never meaning no harm but whereas some
toys like Buzz and Woody remain
good-hearted and heroic Annabelle and
Chucky they broke bad you Charles Lee
ray aka the lakeshore strangler used
voodoo just before he died to transfer
his evil soul into a good guy doll and
Chucky has been sentencing folks to
death ever since that name Charles Lee
ray is a combination of Charles Manson
Lee Harvey Oswald and James Earl Ray all
very bad people to her monsters one was
a patsy
moving on you have got to be kidding
Annabelle takes the all-time cake though
simply because inside of her playful
exterior the devil himself or at least a
high-ranking demon officer the story is
based on a Raggedy Ann doll that was
reported to be inhabited by a demon so
if we're lining this up is a grudge
match a serial killer is bad but Satan
is Satan and even if this isn't the
Satan and it's just some run-of-the-mill
demon that still takes precedent over a
murderer murderers go to hell but you
know who runs that joint demons like the
one that hangs out inside of Annabelle
congratulations demon spirit your toy
Annabelle wins the wild-card round so
now that it's tied at 2 to 2 I have to
break this with my pick I'm thinking
about who I would rather spend a night
with so you're in a bedroom you're
sleeping and the toys on the shelf and
as scary's Annabelle is there's a chance
she just does creepy stuff in your
closet and freaks you out Chucky he's
grabbing a knife and he's going to kill
you like there's no surviving a night
with the Chuckster I feel like the demon
and Annabelle might have other things to
attend to and forget about the terrified
grown man shaking under the covers like
I want no part of either one but I'm
giving Chucky to win here now he'll move
on to face the ventriloquist puppet from
The Twilight Zone
oh [ __ ] you absolutely sorry pal you go
[ __ ] them up real good and for free
right now you can vote on who wins the
Annabelle versus Chucky match head to
the comments section right now and let
us know your pick and why thanks for
watching everyone
sleep tight kiddo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]